i'm at this event called eight percent
nation i was kind of telling you about
this and at the top i talked about two
topics
and i gave the story of jane elliott
that tom shared with me the story of the
third grade teacher and we talked about
propaganda and gaslight
gaslighting one of the things i talked
about is i said
if you're not too careful like in high
school
in junior high school what was gerard's
reputation
what did 50 other kids think of gerard
gerrard was who
in junior high school junior high school
eighth grade who was gerard
uh a little chubby kid got bullied and
uh
was good at sports but pretty shy okay
there you go let's stay there
who what was what did kids say about tom
ellsworth in eighth grade
three things what you joke too much you
talk too much but you're a smart guy and
i want to be work with you on projects
okay perfect go to senior year what did
they say about tom ellsworth
what did they say about gerard and
senior that dude's the man really
seriously okay so you went from eighth
grade
shy kid chubby decent athlete but you
know
football freshman year changed
everything but weight room senior year
yeah he's the man three spot senior year
who were you
senior year uh people knew i was really
smart i still joked a little too much
i still talked a little too much but
people said you're going to do something
okay now go to 30 years old what was
your reputation at 30 years old
matter of fact just go to 25 you
graduated from college what are you
doing at 25
what was your reputation at 25 uh
it was my la last year in the minor
leagues was probably somebody that was
hanging on to a dream too long
probably somebody was staying at the
party too long okay so that's 25.
yeah were you were you fun to party with
did you did you have the reputation
probably too much yeah okay tom 25 what
was tom's reputation uh
i was so that was my
25 years old was my second job it was at
la cellular
and i had gotten promoted twice because
i just got it done and i think the
reputation without any ego in it was
he gets it done okay so here's what i'm
going to with this
uh today what's tom's reputation today
what's gerard's reputation today go to
your reputation today right whatever it
may be you don't have to say just think
about it right
here's the point i'm trying to make to
you how many times
have you recreated your reputation
and your identity how many times many
many times
and by the way some are currently going
through maybe trying to recreate our
their identity
right some of us may be going through
recreating our identity right now nobody
knows about it we want to be known as
hey
this is what i've been known for for the
last five years i'm gonna work on xyz
right
i don't know i think obama may be
wanting to recreate his identity to come
out and say hey
you know this is my position now i know
a lot of you guys have put me in this
box as i'm this person
and some of you guys have put me in the
boxes i'm this person but i kind of want
to recreate my identity this is who i
really am at this phase of my life based
on the experiences i've had
that that's what i foresee if this were
to happen
it would be because i'm not who any of
you guys think i am there's a part of me
of who i am that you think i am yes that
is who i am
but there's a part of me you know
nothing about i am at this phase of my
life and i want to be known for
that and a synergist to me i don't think
the book power versus force you ever
read the book power versus force by
david
uh can you pull up power versus force
chart
pull up power versus force charge yeah
the rainbow the rainbow triangle
yeah if you pull up power versus forces
a chart go to images
so this is what he talks about in this
book it's a powerful book by the way
i read this 20 years ago if you can make
it bigger so everybody can see it okay
there you go lowest level of where to be
is shame
okay this is a level of consciousness it
goes from shame to guilt to apathy to
grief to fear to desire to anger to
pride
first level of consciousness where
you're actually becoming a leader and
living a bit of a
freer life is courage then it's
neutrality neutrality is you can
entertain opposing conversations
then you're willing to have a
conversation you're willing to be open
to it
then your acceptance of people i accept
the fact that you're different than me i
accept the fact that we have differences
then it's reason you have the ability to
reason let's reason an issue together
then it goes to love joy peace
enlightenment right a synergist
is love and above a synergist is loving
above
you want to be a synergist let's make
this happen you want to be a synergist
let's make this happen i think in this
year if you look at trump or obama
you'd probably put trump in what level
what level would you put trump
what level would you put obama if you
put it there uh
trump somewhere between pride and
courage okay obama
acceptance and reason um
courage yeah and i'd put them in the
same place
so both in the same place okay maybe
somebody say hi somebody say lord but
the point is if you want to get to the
next level
where your legacy say this guy you've
reunited america
i think that's that's a that's a long
time i don't think it would take a lot
of
uh courage for him to sit down with with
you or or trump
i think that that's something that he
would welcome he would want to do the
courage is standing up to his team
that's going to tell him there's nothing
in this for you that more importantly
barack there's nothing in this for us
there's nothing in this room he has to
lower america more than dnc
he has to love america more than he
loves the dnc oh i don't know if he does
i don't think that's the question he has
to love america more than he loves
democrats i don't know if there's a
democrat that i
know right now that loves america more
than they love the democratic party
yeah mansion would be america more than
a democratic party i don't know him
though but yeah
mansion would be mentioned would be a
guy that loves america more than the
democratic and i think there's a few
others as well by the way
but if obama's at a point right now that
it's more america
than a democratic party you would do to
sit down
i'm just saying if it is if it's really
america more than your party you would
do to sit down
if it's if it's really more america than
the republican party
trump would do to sit down i think trump
doesn't sit down no problem no problem
does it he does it no
problem so but it's advantageous in
fairness
to him it's it's political more than it
is for him to do it
do you think it do you think it helps
him more you think it helps trump more
if this becomes a reality
i but i don't think i don't see this as
a debate i don't
i see this i don't either i see this is
you're trying to facilitate solutions
yeah i almost want to bring them
together i ask literally three four five
questions and then they go go
for it that's that's my only outcome is
not even to ask any ques it's not like
so tell me
it's okay boom boom boom then i say look
what questions do you have for one
another
you know we have a few different issues
to go through i think these are the
things that
america would like to know what are your
thoughts on these three different issues
i'd be curious enough you guys have
questions for each other how do we get
here
and then president obama asked trump
questions president trump asked obama a
question we just sit there and listen
and it can go 90 minutes where no one's
saying anything but they're talking to
each other
that's what i think the world wants to
see this is not like a
moderator so tell me you got two minutes
for an answer no this is not that
this is what's really on your mind yeah
what how do you think we got here
what part of it do you think is on your
side what part of you think is on their
side and to your point you know who
really would probably be the most pissed
off is the extremes
like the the crazy maggot right and
crazy
would hate they'd hate it they would
hate this aoc would hit it yeah yeah
bernie would hate it which which is why
i want to see it all the more because
i don't think they love america i think
they're kind of on the marxist side of
things
sorry but well that's the whole
buildback better thing that i was
talking about before this the global
thing right
the buildback better things were
quantifiably
like quantifiably better than they've
ever been before
humans had more access to nutrients we
were safer their people were living
longer
humanity three years ago had never
reached the levels that we reached
we have we basically have recreational
in in 80 years
we went from horse and buggy to
recreational space flights
you know what i'm saying like we're
killing it as a species
but we're being presented with this idea
that that you know london bridge is
falling down
we have to build back better this thing
was the system wasn't working
dude it's it's marx's bs you can't sell
revolution
in times of prosperity so they have to
present this image that
things were crumbling and they weren't
things were going great
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye